this is a production of Cornell
University
thanks very much very nice to see you
all here I need to go back to my first
so I'm going to talk to you about a
perhaps more commonplace vegetable than
what you heard about and how it fits in
the food revolution and that is broccoli
get this guy to go so there is a
revolution in the food system when it
comes to vegetables there's a
revolutionary rise in consumption that
you may not even be aware of so this is
a graph of how much broccoli people eat
in a year in America and it may surprise
you that sometime earlier in your
lifetime people in America did not eat
broccoli pretty much it wasn't very well
known at all and there's been a pretty
much continuous rise since about 1970
partly as a result of introduction of
some high high quality hybrid broccoli
varieties in the 1960s and so the
production was able to rise and broccoli
is actually one of the most consumed of
the cooked green vegetables so that the
biggies are tomatoes and potatoes
in other words pizza and french fries
right so we're talking about public
health and increasing vegetable
consumption with that public health goal
so the pizza and fries are probably not
the ones we want to be leading with
broccoli is one that's sort of a symbol
of a healthy food so there's a
revolution going on in the consumption
and we're working on a revolution in
where that is happening so this is a
graph that or a diagram that shows where
broccoli is currently produced so orange
is summertime blue is wintertime and you
can see right away there's some big
blobs in California that is where the
broccoli comes from the desert in the
wintertime and on the cold Pacific coast
where the fog comes in at night and
broccoli happy in the summertime it is
possible to grow in the east as long as
you're in the northern most coldest
county in these and it is possible to
grow in the winter if you are in a
particular spot in the sheltered
Atlantic coast of Florida not too far
north or too far south so there's a
couple of spots where it has been
working but if we're going to really
increase the production across the
country increase the availability for
people who want local and there is a
considerable demand for local in the
east and also if we want to think about
this food security in the country so
last year in California was very driest
and probably heard and in those coastal
counties where they were irrigating the
broccoli from wells they depleted the
water table so far down that the Pacific
Ocean started moving in underneath some
of the best farmland in the country so
that's not a good thing that puts us at
risk to be dependent on creating that
sort of problem so distributing the
production across the country is good
not only to meet the local demand the
environmental benefits of that but
really to make sure that we have a
secure supply of some of these
vegetables that are critical to our
health so the challenge with moving the
broccoli over since you see it's pretty
polarized on the East Coast is that
we're trying to make it grow in a place
that it really doesn't want to in the
summertime in the East it's warm and
humid at night and the broccoli depends
on cool temperatures to become broccoli
and what we see in the marketplace very
specific parts of what's actually a
continuum in nature and so these are
some very closely related genotypes at
what we'd call harvest maturity and you
probably recognize the first one so
that's that's a familiar market class
this is actually sold as a product in
part
written in Italy this one's called
purple cauliflower this one you pretty
much can't buy that the denia recognizes
the typical supermarket broccoli and
mrs. Sarah Chinese kale so that what's
happening here is the flower buds are
getting bigger at maturity and there's a
there's a huge range of what's possible
and we only like those two in the u.s.
marketplace it has to get exactly that
and so the problem is when we move a
California variety to the East Coast and
grow it during the growing season it
doesn't know what to do it produces this
you're not going to buy that and even
the varieties that were developed for
the summertime produce this and you're
still not going to buy that you're not
going to have the opportunity to buy
that so this is where we think about how
to develop broccoli that meets the
consumer demand and so what can we do to
identify the consumer demand so I'll
start with that part that you might say
well you know it's local people will
accept that it's okay if it's local the
the weird weird look good taste fine
cooks fine the yields fine people will
just educate the consumer and make them
accept this and I experienced with
educating consumers to do what we think
they should do is very very limited I
don't even try anymore
the second factor in this is that
there's a very specific gatekeeper the
supermarket produce warehouseman they
accept the product so when a truck comes
up with vegetables for that supermarket
they go through and they decide which of
it they're actually going to buy if it's
not good enough they send it back with
the farmer and when it's a perishable
product that has essentially no value so
the risk of delivering something that's
not absolutely acceptable to the
supermarket buyer is enormous you
can't take that risk as a as a grower
with broccoli there I think they're
especially finicky because broccoli is
sort of a comfort food for a lot of
people and so our comfort zone on
comfort foods is pretty narrow
we like familiarity with comfort foods
we like novelty in other areas but we
want our comfort foods to be very
consistent and so that's where getting
the broccoli to stop doing these things
that's fun I put in there it froze
leaves out also so what we've done with
a rather large team of scientists and
breeders is to do a lot of science which
I won't you any details of website
either these are the developing flower
buds and the white stuff our genes
turning on the control the enlargement
of the flowers which is the process
we're looking at and so we've taken my
latest techniques in genomics the
genetic resources that are available in
the germ plasm collections worldwide and
in the commercial breeding programs we
work very closely with commercial
breeders as well as the public breeders
to bring all that to bear on developing
a broccoli that will look normal even
though the temperatures it's experience
or anything but normal
based on its expectations and so this is
what we have now that's actually a
recently released commercial variety
that was grown here last summer when it
was very very hot and I took all those
other pictures of other materials so
we've gotten to the point where we can
have what looks like a normal flower bud
development so we are working with the
the Wilder material that was brought in
that's part of the public programs is
where the public programs are absolutely
critical they'll make crosses that
wouldn't even be considered in the
private industry and then actually
license that material to the commercial
companies who then develop varieties and
sell those varieties that's what they're
good at so we've got a good team going
to try to bring this out so we're quite
far along on solving this problem
there's a few challenges that still
remains one of the key things for
keeping customers is a year-round supply
so having broccoli coming from somewhere
on the East Coast for the entire year is
important so that's we're connecting
Maine and Florida with New York being a
very large producer for summer and fall
is important but the one most
challenging season is the springtime and
so I'll show you this is one of the more
detailed things that's turning out to be
an issue so they look pretty similar
don't they it turns out there's a
critical difference and that side branch
is relatively short this side branch is
a little bit longer it's just enough
longer but it's a little bit Wiggly and
when you pack all the broccoli together
all those side branches push against
each other and wiggle and look ugly
that's not okay because then when you
put them out on the grocery store shelf
they're not attractive enough and the
staff will toss them and this happens in
the springtime when it's they've been
growing under cold conditions and then
it starts to warm up and you start to
harvest them then that branch starts to
grow a little bit earlier than it would
otherwise place at a tiny detail but it
makes a difference between what you can
sell and not sell and there's another
difference that shows up if you look at
the open spaces in the top of this head
you'll see that they're a little bit
smaller than the open spaces in this one
and that means that you have to put four
or five more of these heads in a box
than you do of those and again they're
less firm
and so they don't ship as well so those
are issues that we still need to deal
with we're discovering this spring issue
is actually a fairly new one we didn't
know they were going to do that because
nobody was growing it in that season
before and that's we're working with
commercial breeders who have experience
in adjusting with all of these subtle
traits he's coming in because it looks
very normal at the end but behind it
we're doing we're really having a
revolution in the amount of consumption
where the production is happening how
we're getting the broccoli to market
from new areas and also the science
behind it learning a whole lot about how
flowers develop and so we're hoping to
see broccoli not develop additional
trait like presumptuousness
pretentiousness but it's continuing to
be one of the biggest comfort foods and
we want to make better broccoli locally
available for as much of the East Coast
as we can thank you this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at Cornell edu